[Musique]
enfin un temps splendide ottawa pour la
grande célébration mais c'est
fantastique c'est pas trop c'est pas
trop chaud sec et ensoleillé comme je
dis il n'y a pas de pluie c'est ce
montage des réjouissances coloris une
foule cosmopolite qui se voulait à
l'image du canada j'aime boire tellement
bien ensemble qui portent des vêtements
différents ensembles au canada la fête
du canada toujours si grand classique
qu'il soit dans la foule sur scène ou
dans les airs
mais qui a aussi réservé aux milliers de
spectateurs quelques surprises imaginez
que j'ai une personne toute spéciale qui
aimerait vous parler aujourd'hui grand
grand représenter tous durant cette
mission spatiale
comme chaque année le premier ministre a
abordé les grands thèmes canadiens
chaque jour les canadiens démontrent au
reste du monde qu une société
multiculturelle et inclusive est une
société forte mais la politique s'est
aussi invitée dans les célébrations
en effet justin trudeau rappelant au
passage les batailles il est succès de
son mandat qui tire à sa fin
comme la levée des tarifs américains sur
l'a6 aluminium ou encore la création de
millions d'emplois au pays depuis quatre
ans
pour le public des questions qui
demeurent loin de leurs préoccupations
en ce début d'été les gens surtout le
coeur à la fin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]